- Guys, this is such exciting times.
How did we get here?
- It was a hot summer day and
Ramin and Mathias' PhD advisor
professor Radu Grosu from
the Technical University of Vienna
was at a meeting in
Europe together with me
and we decided to go for a run together.
And as we were running, we
were talking with each other
about the most exciting
ideas that were on our minds.
And we started talking
about machine learning,
about the large size of
machine learning models
and about how the brain
of the worm only has 300
neurons, 302 to be precise.
And so we both thought that
this was just so exciting
to try to understand how
the natural brains work
and what we might be able to do.
And at the same time, at MIT
we were working on autonomous driving
and we were developing these end-to-end
machine learning models that were
on the order of a
hundred thousand neurons.
And I said,
"Well, I wonder if we can
make our network smaller."
And so Rado said, "Hey, I
have two excellent students,
Ramin Hasani and Mattia Lechner.
Why don't we all get together
to see if we can do that?"
So they came and the rest is history,
Alexander because you joined the team
and we managed to change the model
for learning how to
drive by watching humans
from a hundred thousand
neurons to only 19 neurons.
And that was just transformational.
And to get it all done,
to get it implemented
and to get it actually
in action in the woods
was really extraordinary.
- Yeah, and especially
those early networks when
we were testing them in Fort Devons
completely unseen environments,
training these models here in Cambridge
in urban environments
and then having these liquid
neural networks be deployed
in completely brand new unseen scenarios
was really revolutionary for the field.
- [Man] Absolutely.
- It was really extraordinary to see how
we could train a model
by driving in the city
and have that model perform accurately
and correctly without further training
in a completely different
environment in the woods.
And we started wondering,
why is this happening?
And that's because of the different nature
of liquid networks and
which this was the focus
of Ramin's thesis and Mathias' thesis.
- So we focused on the brain
of the worm, as you mentioned.
We started understanding
how neurons communicate
with each other in order
to create behavior.
And we wanted to create kind of, you know
a level of abstraction of
models that is close enough
to the natural learning systems.
But at the same time they are executable,
and you can actually run them
on real world applications.
And then, so we came up
with this abstract model that each node
of the system is given by
a differential equation.
And they are communicating with each other
through synapses that
are nonlinear functions,
that are input dependent.
And this way you can
create a learning system
that is much more abstract
and small at the same
time is more expressive.
And throughout the years,
like we showed a lot
of theoretical properties of these models,
we showed that they're
most expressive type
of continuous time neural networks.
We showed them that they can
model time series data really well.
And obviously they become
like a perfect candidate
for closed loop and kind of
safety critical applications,
like autonomous driving or
autonomous navigations of drones
or medical time series modeling
and those kind of applications.
And the core behind these things.
Like we were also like wondering
like how is that possible
that we can get such good
results for driving into
like performing lane keeping very robust
while having 19 neurons.
Then we started studying
and then we figured out
that the true nature of these
equations coming together
is the fact that they can
capture the causal structure
of a task so they can capture causality.
That means they can learn
proper better representations
from data.
So we showed a lot of properties,
theoretical properties
of the systems such as
universality, such as expressivity
and robustness characteristics.
And then we scaled them
into applications in autonomous driving.
- With liquid neural networks,
we're able to achieve
this incredible property
which is the ability to train
in one type of environment
but then deploy in a brand
new unseen environment
that the car has never driven in before.
Similar to how we as humans
are able to learn how to drive
in one city and then be
placed in a brand new city
and also be able to successfully
navigate those new roads.
- Mathias and Alexander, what
did it take for you to go
from the theoretical
models to the implemented
systems that have such
extraordinary behavior?
It was so exciting to see the results.
- Yeah, it's actually was
a very challenging task
because these models were typically used
in neuroscience research
and we try to bring it
into like a machine learning framework
and as well as being able
to run on embedded systems
right on our robot,
where you have some real time requirements
so you need to be really fast.
Moreover, the structure of
typical machine learning models
is fully connected so you can write it
as a matrix multiplication.
However, like because our
models are really sparse,
so we had to come up with clever ideas
of how to make use of this
kind of wire structure
and be very efficient
in terms of computation.
- How did you collaborate
with Alexander on that?
- Yeah, Alexander shared
like some really nice codes
that is able to train a
model that runs on a car.
And basically we modified
it by combining like
the work that I did during (indistinct)
with Ramin and Rado
and combined it with Alexander's code such
that we have a model that can
be trained to drive the car.
- Alexander the C cell
robot car is your baby,
how did you trust his code?
- So these models are built off
of the brain wiring of worm.
So we drove the car very slowly at first.
(group laughing)
Speed of a worm.
- And eventually what
was the maximum speed?
- Yeah, yeah.
Eventually we pushed
the car to its limits,
it steering limits.
In Fort Devons, really the maximum
that we could steer these
cars was 30, 35 miles an hour.
It's a very close track.
So even that speed is even difficult
for humans to drive at that speed.
So we were able to really push
these models to their limits,
their physical limits on the car
which was a huge win
and huge success for us.
- And I think that we took it
even further when we took it
to the drone environment and flying.
So we went from the 2D kind
of camera to control actions
or navigation signals
into the flying drones
and towards objectives.
And not only that, but I mean navigation
of flying agents has
been there for decades.
But what's what's interesting is
that how can we have
intelligent systems that they
can extract the task that they're given.
So, and this is a big question,
fundamental question in machine learning
that how can we extract the actual task
from given data to a
machine learning system?
And I think this is one
of those early evidences that we show
that their liquid neural networks
they can perform reasoning
so they can understand the
task that is given to them.
- Quite similar to the
end-to-end driving scenario
we thought we would take this
to a larger dimensional space where now
we can take it to flight
and use the liquid networks to
pilot the drone autonomously
for a set task that we set out for it.
In this case, the task we trained it
on is to fly towards a series
target that we show it.
A human pilot manually
flies the drone a few times
towards some targets that are set out
that we trained in some woods.
And then we take this data
and train the liquid
networks on these sequences
of data and then we can take the networks
and run them in a variety
of different environments
on tasks that are exactly the same
but also slightly different, but related.
What we're looking to do
next is add multimodality
to these networks.
So at the moment they
only take input images
to run the networks.
We want to see what else we can do,
what other information can
we feed into the network
to have it achieve more complex behavior.
And as we do that, we'll
also be looking to scale it
to multi-agent systems
where we can get not only
one drone achieving a task,
but multiple drones communicating
and achieving more complex tasks.
- There are so many ways
in which the function of
these networks surprised us
in an exciting and positive way.
First of all, I wanna say
that I enjoyed so much going to the track
and doing the experiments
and I had full faith.
In fact, I put my car, my own
personal beloved car was one
of the obstacles that our
vehicle was trying to avoid.
And well there were no
accidents, very happy about that.
But going back to what
you were saying, Ramin,
the causality property of
these networks is very powerful
and it's really amazing
to see how experimentally
we can achieve zero shot learning
on fairly complicated tasks.
And the tasks we studied
most recently is the task
of identifying an object
and tracking an object.
And we could do this
without actually explicitly
telling the system
your task is to find this red
backpack and follow it around.
And so we developed the
solution and then we trained
in the woods using imaging from the summer
when the scene is very
(indistinct), it's green,
it's really a summer scene.
And then the surprising thing was
that we could take the same code
without any further training
and we could show it working
in the fall when we still have leaves
but of a very different texture and color.
And most extraordinarily
we were able to do
the same model and the same solution
for winter where all the leaves were gone
and all we had was black vertical
lines for the tree trunks.
And when we compared our
solution with the solution
of other traditional models
that were trained exactly
as we trained our solution,
we found that ours was
the only one that worked.
In other words liquid networks
were the only ones that could
go from the task trained
in the summer to executing
the task in the fall
and executing the task in the winter.
And I said the winter experiments
were most extraordinary
but actually we had even more
extraordinary experiments
when we went from the woods
into urban environments
and from static objects to moving objects.
And the same models operated
extraordinarily well.
And the way we measured that is by looking
at the attention of the networks
and by showing that in fact
with liquid networks, the
attention is very much focused
on the task, whereas with other solutions
the attention is often
focused on the context.
And so that's why with other solutions,
when you change the context,
you need to change the model.
But with us, with our solution,
with liquid networks, it's very different.
- Yeah, to analyze network
and to really understand like
what has been learned, right?
Because these networks
behave as a black box.
We use a technique called resiliency maps,
where we visualize where
the network is looking at,
where the network is strong attention to
and really to understand
actually what's yeah,
what the network is doing.
And we have been using a couple
of methods maybe, Alexander.
- Yeah, so resiliency
maps basically allow us
to ask this question to
our models, which is,
if you make some decision, why
did you make this decision?
What did you see in your input
and your environment that
made you make this decision?
So resiliency maps are a very visual
and explanatory way for us to
ask those types of questions
to these very traditionally
black box models.
But when we ask these to
liquid neural networks
we're able to get very crisp
and concise answers in the
attention maps that we see back.
And the attention is always
very focused like Daniella said,
exactly on the task that's
supposed to be performing,
even though we never give it
any explicit instruction to
pay attention in those areas.
- So now this was a very
beautiful experimental result
that encouraged us to think
about deeper questions
around machine learning.
And one of the grand challenges
of machine learning is how can we get
a learning based solution
that is interpretable
and explainable?
And this is especially important
for safety critical applications,
like the ones we encounter in robotics.
With liquid networks, because
the solutions we have,
because the models are compact,
for example, in the
case of the driving task
we only need 19 neurons.
Because we have such compact solutions
we can actually associate the behavior
of the network with a decision tree,
which is computable and
it is human understandable
and produces in a more theoretical
framework an explanation
for how these models
reach their decisions.
And I think this is an important next step
towards developing solutions
that are interpretable
and even certifiable for
safety critical applications.
- I think the of artificial intelligence
now very much focused
on the generative AI aspect of things.
And in this space we see that larger
and larger models are getting,
they're booming and they're
performing exceptionally well.
They're getting better and better.
But I think what we have with
liquid networks is kind of
a counter to that kind
of scaling law that shows
that you can actually
achieve intelligent behavior
and especially in the task
of drone manipulation that
we were talking about,
we were training in a complete forest
and then we kind of zero
shot completely transferred
it into a urban area.
That's fascinating.
That's complete out of
distribution generalization.
This behavior emerging
from a network that has 30 liquid neurons
that's I think something that is requires
the attention of the field.
So the field has to actually look into how
heavily under parametrized
neural networks,
such as liquid neural networks,
because of their structure
they can actually generate behavior
and become kind of a potential
for the future generation
of our generative models.
- So that's one direction,
but there are many
other directions, right?
So we would like to have
deeper theoretical results
in understanding the causality,
in defining the mathematics
behind the attention maps,
in expanding more on our
interpretability research
to really get to the
point of certifiability.
I mean, can you imagine
if we get to the point where we have
machine learning based
solutions that are certifiable,
that would be extraordinary.
Because we would be ready
to deploy the solutions
in industry where not making
mistakes is actually important.
- Absolutely.
- And so that's very, very exciting.
The other area that I think
is extraordinarily exciting
is the area of considering
multiple agents,
so multiple robots
or multiple computational units
interacting with each other.
And I'm very excited
about developing a robust and
rigorous theoretical solution
for how we compose solutions that work
on one application into solutions.
And there's just so
much more, for instance,
in medicine, in providing surgeons
with powerful solutions to prevent them
from making mistakes is an area
where we're actively working
with Mathias right now.
And another very important
area is to really think
about the scope of these solutions.
So right now all of our results
are for time series data.
That means that applications
that involve video
or involve sensor output,
these applications are
amenable to liquid networks.
But how would these networks perform
on other types of data?
Can we extend these
extraordinary applications
and performance to
static data, like images
or to text, to a completely
new kind of data source?
- I think liquid networks
can serve as a building block
of the future artificial
intelligence systems
and maybe artificial general
intelligence systems.
And that's my dream
and that's what I'm
gonna work on the future.
- I wanna build generalist
liquid neural networks
that don't solve just a single task,
but a wide variety of tasks
and perform really well
across the board of tasks.
- I really believe, and my
dream is for AI to be largely
embedded into society,
helping us every single day
with a lot of our tasks.
And a lot of the really exciting
advances that we've seen
with AI to date have all been
non embodied intelligence.
So one of the things
that really excites me is
the way that liquid neural networks,
we've now shown this
capability where we can
deploy intelligence into embodied agents
and have intelligence be
actually embedded into society
and helping all of us as
humans in our everyday lives.
- With liquid models, we
begin to understand rigorously
and more theoretically how learning works.
And I'm really excited about
pushing the boundaries here.
Understanding intelligence is
one of the greatest challenges
in science today, and I'm so excited
about the role that
liquid networks will play
in answering many questions
whose answers we do not know today.
With Liquid Networks
we can also create
machine learning solutions
that are explainable,
compact, sustainable,
perhaps even certifiable.
And I'm so excited about the next steps
in developing the mathematical foundations
of liquid networks and
understanding the foundations
for a future with machine
learning that is sustainable,
explainable, causal, and composable.